we interrupt this program to stupid dog
you make me look bad my name boy's voice
crack only it probably had words but
anyway welcome surprise sweetie pie my
weekly check-in with you bros my
subscribers it's great to be back thank
you both for the warm welcome
as you may or may not know I've been
away in LA for a couple days it was like
a bit of a bit of both like a bit of
vacation and a bit of business can't
really talk too much about it but
there's definitely some exciting stuff
coming up for the future I'll let you
know when I can like talk I don't know
we reached the bro army has now reached
half a million subscribers which is
insane like I don't know what happened
all the sudden there's a bunch of bro
streaming in here so it's it's really
cool like I don't know I can't I can't
express myself with these things it's
it's hard to grasp I guess like half a
million it's amazing it's a huge number
you know I'm really happy about it but
still it's just a number and
what really matters to me at least it's
the support that you bros show in all
your videos that's like if that's what
it really means something I think it
means so I'm really happy about it and
you know States stay awesome breasts I
thought we could do another livestream
to celebrate this event so I thought
next Wednesday I haven't decided timing
yet but follow me on Facebook or Twitter
if you want to know these kind of things
so yeah I also thought we'd have like
another competition for you music Bros
you created Bros maybe something that
you liked the last time you pretty much
just make any song that you want that
relates to me leave it as video response
and I'll check it out and I'll choose
the next winner for next Friday we got
some amazing submissions next last last
time so I'm really hoping that we'll get
it again like last winner I think we had
like a million views on the video so
it's pretty good if you're a new guy on
YouTube and you wanna make songs and
shooters and stuff like that
other than that I don't think I had not
that much to say and again thank you
both so much for all the support it's
really like too much sometimes I kind of
feel like oh my god I don't deserve this
but regardless I'm really happy about it
so we're gonna end ish as always and if
you're new oh you better put him up put
him up right now put your fists up
brothers all right here comes sails and
rose ceremony activate